hello hello everyone welcome and thank
you so much for coming I'm Steven pity
I'm professor
of history in American Studies and
ethnicity race and migration and the
director of the Center for the Study of
race indigeneity and transnational
migration it's great to see everyone
here today on Election Day
hope you all those of you who can have
voted really really thrilled to welcome
back to campus moneka Munoz Martinez the
Stanley Jay Bernstein assistant
professor of American Studies at Brown
University moneka was named last year an
Andrew Carnegie fellow as one of quote
the country's most creative thinkers
undertaking quote research on challenges
to democracy and international order a
major honor and a certainly a fitting
one given the work that she does Monica
received her PhD in American Studies
here at Yale and at Brown she offers
courses on Latin X Studies immigration
histories of violence histories of
policing and public memory in United
States history her remarkable first book
the injustice never leaves you
anti-mexican violence in the United
States was just published by Harvard
University Press in September of 2018
recommend it to all of you there are a
number of students in the room who
already had the chance to read it and
she'll be discussing that project here
today Monica Martinez is also the
primary investigator for mapping
violence a digital project at Brown that
documents histories of racial violence
in Texas she's also a founding member
member of the nonprofit organization
refusing to forget an organization that
calls for a public reckoning with racial
violence in Texas that team developed an
award-winning exhibit for the Bullock
Texas State history museum that marked
the first time in Texas history that a
cultural institution
acknowledged Texas's state
responsibility for a period of racial
terror in the ER in the 20th century
Monica has also helped to secure state
historical markers along the us-mexico
border
commemorating racial violence in Texas
and that has kept her very busy indeed
up until just hours ago you were busy
with this with a ceremonial unveiling
and other types of work please join me
in help in welcoming when he came on
Tina's back to you thank you Steve I'm
so happy to be here with you in New
Haven happy a voting Election Day
I I had another outfit planned for today
from Joe's bakery it was a t-shirt
called ethos and vote and I had a
fabulous crushed blue velvet blazer that
I bought several years ago and never had
a reason to wear it and then Oprah stole
my look she wore it before I did and I
talk called my mom and she said well you
can't you know who wore it best with
Oprah Monica so instead I'm wearing a
skirt that I bought you know like when I
was on the job market but if I wanted to
dress for the occasion for the day but
also for coming back to New Haven into
Yale University and to be with faculty
and colleagues that helped to help me
write this book and planted the seats
not only for the injustice never leaves
you but also for the public work and
that helped me develop a practice and it
also feels in many ways like I'm having
the opportunity to continue a
conversation and to help think through
some questions that I still have about
the best way to make histories of racial
violence public I've had a as Steve was
saying an opportunity to present my work
in different communities in Texas and
across the country but also to
participate in public projects and I
still have questions about you know what
how the responsible ways for bringing
these histories to the public and for
engaging different communities in
conversations about histories of racial
violence and how to connect truthfully
with the past so I'm so thankful for the
invitation to come back I'm also honored
to participate in celebrating 20 years
of ethnicity race and migration
Yale and I'm so thankful to the faculty
into students in this room that helped
to make it possible to organize and
mobilize to build and dream of the
center it's really inspiring and I'm so
thankful also for nandi for the work
that she did to help bring me here so
I'm gonna do my best to stay still for
the camera and and share a bit with you
from the book I want to give you know a
quick overview of just some of the
interventions that the book makes and
that I think has has helped lead to the
reception the good reception that the
book has received so to give people just
a broader sense of the interventions
I'll actually read a section of the book
to help introduce some of the quick case
study and also give people a sense of
the methods and the questions that I
engage in the book and then after that
I'm gonna talk through some of the
problems and challenges with actually
bringing about a public reckoning and
dialogue about this history of racial
violence so I also can I get a sense of
how many people in the room have read
the book it was a good number okay and
how many of you know nothing about
history of anti-mexican violence in
Texas okay all right so we've got a
range of audience I just wanted to get a
sense so just very broadly my book the
injustice never leaves you grapples with
a period of anti-mexican violence in
Texas in the early 20th century it was a
period between 1910 and 1920 that was a
reign of terror state sanctioned it was
a reign of terror enacted by a coalition
of Texas Rangers the state police
officers in Texas local law enforcement
officers Anglo vigilantes and US
soldiers and so striking the parallels
that I see from a hundred years ago and
today in terms of the culture of
anti-mexican violence so in the early
20th century there was a politicians the
media and local residents criminalized
ethnic Mexicans as bandits
threats to the nation as threats to
Anglos more specifically and also as
threats to Anglo capital capitalism and
so you saw a period of in which there
were calls to increase the police
presence on the border in 1914 the
government responded by sending over a
hundred thousand US troops to the border
and so you know the the criminalization
of ethnic Mexicans in this period was
answered by the brutal policing of this
intersection regime of law enforcement
officers soldiers and an Anglo
vigilantes and the one of the tensions
in the book is that in this period there
was an effort to justify the violence
and that led to public understandings of
this period in this period of
anti-mexican violence actually being
progress and so one of the tensions in
the book is that on the one hand there
have been calls for over a hundred years
by people who live in the border lands
people from this era who sought justice
and from generation to generation passed
down an effort to try to change public
understandings of this period of racial
violence but that's intention with a
broad national forgetting of this this
period of anti-mexican violence and so
it's estimated that between 1910 and
1920 that hundreds of ethnic Mexicans
were murdered by these agents and that
those victims included American citizens
of Mexican descent people that were
racialized as Mexican as foreign others
as criminal threats and Mexican
nationals that were living in Texas
during this period and so a good number
of the people that had moved into South
Texas in this period were refugees
fleeing the violence of the Mexican
Revolution and so in this period most
people publicly have forgotten this
these calls for violence and this period
of racial terror and
and one of the interventions that I make
in the book is not only to document the
kinds of violence the widespread
violence but but also to document the
ways in which this kind of violence was
institutionalized
and so for his for historians of the
borderlands other historians that have
written about this period of violence
there's a long tradition of historians
starting from the early 20th century
well with Walter Prescott Webb that
really created and institutionalized not
only in the field of history but also in
public history a progress narrative that
that Mexicans are a violent group of
people that they are racially inferior
that they have dirty water trough water
for blood and that Texas Ranger
brutality at the hands of Texas Rangers
of state police officers would actually
progress you know made it secured the
border for Anglo capital and for Anglo
Americans but one of the ways in which I
think that the Borderlands historians
that have returned to this period to
actually expose the brutality and expose
the murders of people the denial of due
process for ethnic Mexicans in this
region is that historians have also
fallen into this trap of looking at this
period as ending in nineteen twenty and
so in in nineteen nineteen JT canalis
who was a state representative from
Brownsville he helped to lead an
investigation into the Texas Rangers and
so the the some of the acts of brutality
become so egregious namely the board
made Massacre in January 1918 it was the
the massacre of fifteen men and boys who
were in the custody of Texas Rangers
this community was interrupted by a
group of Texas Rangers local ranching
family and local ranchers and they were
supported by a US cavalry troop and in
the middle of the night this community
was awoken taken from their homes and
this group of 15 men and boys was
executed and so that event caused sort
of put a spotlight on the kinds of
brutality that had been occurring over
the decade and in 1919 there was an
investigation
to the Texas Rangers which led to weeks
of of investigations but as a result of
the crimes that were brought to light
from that investigation the Texas Ranger
force was reduced in number so part of
the the escalation of policing in this
period took the form of the the Texas
State Police Force growing dramatically
from under less than 100 Texas Rangers
in 1914 by 1919 there was 1,350 Texas
Rangers approximately and so one of the
ways that the state responded to the
disc these kinds of acts of brutality
being exposed was to reduce the numbers
of the Texas Rangers drastically and so
they reduced the force from over 1,300
to less than 75 and so even for
historians that have returned to this
period to recover in this period of
violence they've sort of understood the
Canales investigation is leading to the
end the decline of this kind of
brutality and so part of the work that
I've done is to trace the movement of
some of these Texas Rangers and police
officers to track the kinds of violence
that they participated in different
parts of the state but also to note that
and to highlight quite clearly that
firing somebody from the Texas Ranger
Police Force is not justice for murder
and that in fact the Texas Rangers some
of the Mo's by what the with the
bloodiest records were released from the
forest just before the investigation
began and so there were crimes that were
documented that were never heard before
the committee but in many cases like the
Texas Rangers that participated in the
Floyd veined Massacre some of them that
were released went on to become you know
sheriff's to work in local law
enforcement and some of them actually
returned back to the Texas Ranger force
years later and so I've tried to in this
project expose the the longer roots of
this period of violence and how it
shaped institutions of policing and
cultures of policing and to raise
concerns about the periodization of this
period of violence and
in in 1920 and that's you know one of
the other parts of this project was to
also show the ways in which policing
culture shapes societies more broadly
and so in understandings of racial
violence in US history most often people
think about mob violence so you know
think about lynchings and in the history
in Texas there's not only a deep history
of lynching so the n-double a-c-p ranked
Texas third in the nation for having the
highest numbers of lynchings just just
behind Georgia and Mississippi for the
numbers of anti-black lynchings in Texas
between eighteen eight eighteen
forty-eight and nineteen twenty eight
Texans lynched over two hundred ethnic
Mexicans and so there is a deep culture
of mob violence but some of the work
that I do is to actually show the ways
in which the police themselves were
agents of racial terror practicing extra
legal forms of violence and targeting
multiple racial and ethnic groups and so
one of the the projects that I developed
after I left Brett Yale was to study the
role of the Texas Rangers and
intimidating n-double-a-cp chapters
across the state and participating in
mob violence by leaving prisoners
unarmed and so part of the work too is
trying to expose how these histories of
racial violence are deeply
interconnected in a place like Texas you
can map how the state is acting to
create this reign of terror but for too
long violence at the hands of police has
been shielded in a cloak of legal
authority and in large part that's
because of the reliance of some type of
early historians like Walter Prescott
Webb on the use of Texas Ranger records
and seeing what Rangers were producing
as truth and so I want to read so I'll
do a little a reading from the book
before moving on to to two other points
about the the interventions of the book
so I open with for people who are not
from Texas a scene from Brownsville at
the southernmost
point of the state brownsville borders
Matsumoto's you can see it there and
here's a picture from robert Runyon's
collection an aerial photograph of the
us-mexico border in the 19-teens the
community on the south south just south
of the border is matsumoto-san north is
brownsville and so you get the sense of
how intimately connected these
communities were people would live on
one side of the river and owned a
business on the other side people moved
fluidly and so the calls to militarize
the border in this era really was trying
to create a divide between communities
and so that was something that new Anglo
settlers that arrived in South Texas in
the early 20th century wanted to create
an international border that felt like a
division rather than just a river so I
opened the book with a story of
florencio Garcia it was an otherwise
ordinary day in early April 1918 but
Miguel Garcia a Mexican national living
in Texas was growing concerned his son
florencio 25 years old had not yet
returned home from his job as a cattle
herder in Cameron County gutsy I started
walking through town asking relatives
friends neighbors and eventually even
the county attorney and local law
enforcement officers if they had seen
Florencio days passed without news then
someone told Garcia at Texas Rangers had
arrested florencio over a week earlier
on April 5th
just south of Brownsville Garcia knew
that when ethnic Mexicans disappeared
after being arrested
the prisoners remains were often found
hidden in the grove of mesquite trees in
the rural Texas landscape this grim news
prompted Garcia to start searching the
brush in the countryside for his son's
remains Miguel Garcia repeatedly asked
for help from local authorities Oscar
Dancy the Cameron County Attorney
remembered Garcia's persistence the old
man the father of the boy was at my
office he was at my office two or three
times and my residence once weeks later
local residents found human remains
outside of Browns
Phil Dancy remembered we found the bones
of a human being we found a pair of
pants and a jumper and as I recollect it
a shirt black hair and a hat a light
Texas cowboy Stetson hat and he added
that there were bullet holes noticed in
the jacket two perhaps three the
clothing matched the description Miguel
got Asiya had previously provided and
the investigation suggested that but
that the body had been shot in the back
three times the remains consisted only
of clothes a skull with a tuft of hair
and bones scattered as far as 300 yards
likely by coyotes or buzzards Garcia
arrived at the scene and identified the
shoes hat and clothing as belonging to
flawed NCO the father pulled a monograph
handkerchief out of the jacket they had
discovered and verified that it was his
sons so the story of Miguel Garcia
looking for his father I decided to to
write about this to open the book for a
few reasons what ended up playing out
what I ended up finding in the archives
thanks to the investigations by the
Mexican Consulate that investigated this
case was that there were witnesses -
florencio being in the custody of the
state police there were witnesses that
found him that saw him being held in a
jail County Jail and then there were
witnesses that saw him leaving the
county jail in the custody of Texas
Rangers and so from this account Miguel
Garcia pressured local authorities to
investigate the murder of his son and he
also pressured local authorities to
offer to write a death certificate for
his son and so this became crucially
important in the archives for me being
able to tell the history not only of the
father's efforts of the family's efforts
but to find a document that that
confirmed at florencio Garcia died and
so this is an important find you know it
includes information biographical
information of
Florencio his date of birth for example
his occupation as a cattle herder the
birthplace his birthplace but also the
names of his parents we don't have here
access to the name of his wife but we
have information about who testified and
identified the body it was Miguel Garcia
we also have information here about the
date of his burial so we know that his
family did bury the remains of Florencio
but we also see interesting note here
where the coroner actually had to amend
the document so he had to amend the
primary source because of the conditions
under which the body was found and so he
didn't have information about when he
died he didn't have information you know
he couldn't say the last I saw him or
her alive was on this date and so he
actually you know scratched through the
text on the forum and said that I
attended that I found the identified
remains and the death occurred on
unknown date and so with this
interesting moment in the archives where
you see that this body that the remains
of florencio is literally falling out of
the ways in which a coroner would
traditionally write one of these
documents and of course here it must
have been unsettling for the family to
see that the cause of death was unknown
especially given that they found and the
investigation found that there were
bullet holes in the back of the jacket
but because the remains had been so far
decomposed the coroner I'm guessing is
one of the reasons that they use to not
include that that the cause of death was
you know being shot or murdered but one
of the reasons why this document is also
so important is that there it directly
contrasts and undermines the efforts by
the Texas Rangers that participated in
arresting Florencio and that had been
identified as having him in his custody
when he was last seen alive they
actually wrote and testified that they
had released florencio that they caused
him no harm and that actually that he
had been seen across the border in
Matamoros
and that perhaps he just didn't want he
wanted to abandon his family and and so
despite this death certificate being
written
despite florencio being buried by his
family there's not only the the Texas
Rangers continued to deny any
involvement in his death but with this
death certificate in hand float until
got to see his family was able to have
the three Texas Rangers arrested they
were released on bond and placed back
into custody of their you know the
supervision of the captain that they
worked under and a a grand jury decided
not to indict the Texas Rangers and so
there's no prosecution of the Texas
Rangers but we do have this death
certificate and for the you know the
estimates that hundreds of ethnic
Mexicans died in this period is an
estimate because part of the acts of
violence was that there was no
consistent effort to record the deaths
and so we have access to the writings of
journalists who wrote articles about
these deaths we have access to some of
these rare documents like these death
certificates access to mexican consulate
records so in this case because florida
nco was a Mexican national the Mexican
consul could be involved in calling for
an investigation and in large part
that's what led to at least the arrest
of the Texas Rangers and the pressure to
have this death certificate issued but
of course the grand jury was not under
the control of the Mexican consul or the
requests of the father and so there's no
prosecution of the Texas Rangers here
and the the effort to undermine the
pleas and the calls for justice that we
see not only in the effort they do the
several attempts of Miguel Garcia to go
and ask the county attorney for help in
finding his son and then asking for the
death certificates to be issued then
calling for the arrest of his son we see
that all disavowed by the state by the
Texas Ranger captain Stevens who
testified in the Gonzalez investigation
in 1919
and he in his report disputed that
Florencio gotta SIA even died so here we
see in the questions did you interrogate
the men and investigate the facts and
did you decide in your own mind whether
or not they had anything to do with the
death if he is dead he's being
interviewed here by the attorneys
representing the state and Stevens
replies I investigated they statements
they made and I went to Brownsville and
I heard through a Mexican that this man
was seen across the river after they
turned him loose yes after they turned
him loose
I spoke to deputy sheriff who made the
investigation he stated that he did not
think that this was the body of Garcia
that those bones had been there quite a
long time right so again they're also
disputing that the identification of the
son's remains you don't know that Floyd
SEO guys oh you don't know that fluid
until Garcia had a reputation of being a
notorious cow thief on the other side of
the river I heard this after the
investigation and if there was
cooperation with the authorities and so
you know the the investigation goes on
but in this document we see that
florencio gotta SIA is still there still
denying that he died they're still
denying the identification of him and
you also see the criminalization of the
dead right and do you know and you don't
know right that he was a notorious cow
thief so this pattern in 1918 gives us
just a glimpse into the to the other
cases in this case we actually have a
name of the victim but there's many
others that we don't have the names of
and so this was this case and others are
important for also putting on display
and exposing the ways in which the state
authorities participated in justifying
violence covering crimes and
criminalizing the dead and that is
something that in and even in the the
public you know mainstream accounts of
this period that celebrated violence or
that justified have mitigated the
violence they they often cast blame on
rogue agents and so the work that I did
in the in the book is also to expose the
roles of governor's u.s. congressman
that called for violence and said things
like congressman Hudspeth said you know
I will lead a mob against them
those bandits you've got to shoot them
when you see them right so this is also
the namesake of Hudspeth County in West
Texas so who also then went on in 1924
to write into legislation a 1 million
dollar writer to the Immigration Act of
1924 to build the Border Patrol
right so Kelley Lydell Adnan this has
done excellent work in tracing the roots
of the the development of the Border
Patrol being in being built by former
Texas Rangers but but men like Hudspeth
who called for violence and justified
even mob violence imagined a federal
force built-in like of the Texas Rangers
so so enough about the state the other
sort of key departure in my book is
think is is really you know like
utilizing feminist research methods and
so the in the period of the examinations
of this violence the work before had
primarily focused on conflict between
men Anglo men and Mexican men and the
work that I did you know being really
inspired by my training in gender and
sexuality studies in women in gender
studies but also in in critical analysis
of the work of women and mothers in
calling out injustice in Latin America
throughout the 20th century and most
recently in the 1980s and 90s and and
through today I was really captivated by
what it meant to study and document as a
historian what it was like to live in a
reign of terror and so that requires
that we examine the aftermath and and a
lot of the the good foundational work in
Borderlands history has contributed to
collecting the names of people who died
you know a body count but if we think
about trying to get a glimpse into how
terror shaped daily life it requires us
to ask what happened after florencio
Garcia was buried and in that case I
don't have any more information into
where the family moved where they left
but other signal cases
that I selected for the book gave us
access to the longer legacy that these
acts of violence had in shaping
generations of families but also shaping
communities for over a century
and this is also building on the work
like other historians like Kidada
Williams
who insist that historians have to do
more than just study the violence events
of racial violence so in in this has
helped to really send her the work of
women and also provide a gendered
understanding of these kind but the
dynamics of racial violence and and what
I found was that in erasing or
forgetting what happened in the
aftermath of violence we have foreclosed
the possibilities of exposing the
methods that were available for seeking
justice for the surviving relatives so
finding you know having pushing for an
investigation pushing for a death
certificate but I also found the work of
widows and children who filed
legislation you know lawsuits against
the US government namely Mexican
nationals that sought to hold the state
accountable for their murder of their
husbands or their children and so you
know this was really an important legal
archive to stumble into because it gave
us access to what happens for Mexican
nationals what were the possibilities
when local courts fail to prosecute and
so in some cases there were families who
did receive indemnities from the US
government for either the failure of the
state to prosecute mob participants or
for the direct involvement of US
soldiers or law enforcement agents like
the Texas Rangers in the murder of their
children but you know I also was really
attentive to the the burden that these
families had to carry in testifying
repeatedly throughout the investigations
to Mexican consuls to us consuls to
County officials and and and in thinking
through the dynamics of having to attend
to the violence of
on the body in an effort to seek justice
and so that introduced me to not just
the work of women in in seeking justice
immediately in the aftermath but it also
introduced me to families who had been
connected by this period of violence by
a broadly felt injustice and so it was
an injustice not just from learning the
histories and learning about the
violence the violent acts themselves
learning that people weren't prosecuted
in this period of violence but also
learning that this period of violence
had been disavowed by the state or
erased or silenced or celebrated so
thinking about injustice here in a in
its multifaceted so it's the injustice
of what took place in the 19-teens but
then it's also the continued and
justices that these families carried and
so one person described this to me as
note of my love Gloria Rodriguez is a
one of the leading Texas residents who I
interviewed about the double murder of
her grandfather and great-grandfather
has whose buzz on in Antonio Longoria
they were murdered by a posse of a Texas
Ranger and two civilians Paul West and
William sterling William sterling went
on later to lead the Texas Ranger force
but in 19th in September 1915 her
grandfather and great-grandfather
visited a Texas Ranger a camp in South
Texas and illogical County and to report
that they had been robbed and so they
wanted to report that they had had store
tsa's stolen in the case that the people
that stole these horses were later
arrested the family didn't want these
horses in the custody of these men to
then bring suspicions of them supporting
banditry and in this era even being
suspected or just called being suspected
of bandit bandit tree or sympathizing
with bandits was a license to kill and
so on the way home
Azusa bazan and Antonio Longoria you
know it's reported witnesses later
reported that they you know mounted
their horses to return back to their
ranch and when they had reached about
three hundred yards away from the ranger
campsite these three men loaded into a
Model T Ford drove to the men and shot
them both in the back so part of the
devastating history of this account was
not only the brutality of the
cold-blooded murder
but that also that carry but Texas
Ranger Captain Harry Ransom ordered the
witnesses the laborers on the ranch not
to bury the remains not to tend to the
remains but also not to bury their
remains and so this was an extreme act
of of disrespect and intimidation and so
you know a few days passed before
friends of bazan on Longoria took the
risk and actually buried the remains but
when notable and Gloria Rodriguez
learned of this story it really
interrupted her life and it filled her
with a sense of grief and it left her
with unanswered questions so she turned
to history she visited local libraries
to read history books about this period
of violence she wanted to when she heard
that a Texas Ranger had participated it
disrupted all of her understandings of
the Rangers you know these were the Lone
Ranger and Chuck Norris the heroes that
she had grown up idolizing in school and
so she went to the history books to try
to learn more about this period of by
violence and she found some books but
for the most part she had more questions
and so she also tried to turn to local
archives State Archives
she went to Austin to look at the Texas
Ranger reports she read through
microfilm of local newspapers trying to
find some discussion of this case and
she didn't find anything she didn't find
a death certificate for his whose buzz
on in our dueling Longoria and so
despite dedicating weekends and
vacations to searching state archives
for public records she didn't find these
records and so instead she took on the
task of documenting her family history
and so I actually found
no.11 go together with Regas steve pity
in the middle of my dissertation
research supported me an email because
she had published an essay called
silence of the heart which gave a
history of her grandmother's her and her
great-grandmother epic minnieofoz on and
on Tony along gaudiya that had to live
in the wake of violence and so she wrote
a history of her grandmother and
great-grandmother and gave an account of
the double murder and she published it
in a local in a digital publication
called somos Primos and so you know I
visited her I conducted an oral history
with her for about two hours and then
she brought out a piece of you know I
thought the interview was done so I was
packing up my stuff and then she brings
out a piece of pie and some iced tea and
then she brings out photographs and then
she brings out pictures oh that's the
same thing she brings home photographs
and maps and a teaching certificate of
Antonio Longoria's and a letter that
describes him as the Hidalgo County
Commissioner and so she started to bring
me documents that proved that the two
men had lived and she showed me
photographs of the gravestones and then
she brought out documents that gave me
access to who her grandmother and
great-grandmother worker and she told me
stories about Antonia Longoria who she
referred to as mama doncha
you know her grandmother told me about
the baked goods that she made told me
about how they leased out land and just
this weekend I learned about a grove of
peach trees that they had on the ranch
that died after the the after the double
murder because the family couldn't
sustain all of the work on the ranch but
when I asked her about this work and a
sentiment of loss that had remained she
explained it's an injustice it never
leaves you it's inherited loss and the
title of the book the injustice never
leaves you comes from that interview and
it's inspired by the questions that Nord
my Longoria Rodriguez prompted me to ask
that other historians had not
prompted me to ask write historians our
objective stay removed this is not the
field of history of emotions and one of
the unanswered questions that has stayed
with me is that she wished that she had
had the opportunity to ask one of the
witnesses before they passed if her
grandfather and great-grandfather died
quickly did they have a fast death or
did they suffer you know and that is
such a human question you know she
connected intimately with this
grandfather and great-grandfather who
she never knew and more than just
wanting to know the who what where when
and why what were the motives who were
the Texas Rangers when did it happen
she was really lingering in those last
moments with when when the when captain
Ranson ordered people not to tend to the
bodies were they alive you know those
are the questions that she has and those
are the questions that she's continued
to ask but also she's been committed to
making the history public and I remember
sitting in Joanne Meyerowitz his office
in HGS and talking about not about on
going on with Vegas and the elevado's
that I had met and saying these they are
a part of this history the history did
not end in 1918 when the massacre
happened and and you know they were
making history they were writing their
own history and so this is you know some
coming from the archive of Norman Gloria
Rodriguez this is a photograph of his
sous bazan you know this was on display
in the Bullock museum the Bullock museum
pulls from archives like the Library of
Congress the Autry museum in LA the
Texas State Archives but they didn't
know how Seuss buzz on and they didn't
have a picture of him and they also
didn't have this stunning photograph of
epic many Amazon
here she is and her granddaughter's this
is Louisa you know surrounded by the
plants and with the bird in the corner I
just love this photograph you know and
if I could be this if I could just pose
like that all the time
but this was this is a photograph that
that Christine Cody
excuse me Christine melis her mother
Melba Cody had in their home that they
donated it relent to the Bullock museum
to have on display and they also had
this photograph of Antonio Longoria and
Antonia Longoria and the inscription on
the back is really beautiful it's
written to their friends who they call
their brothers right you know the
familial connection here and so this was
taken in 1895 and so these are the kinds
of documents that the families had
preserved they had participated in
preserving and archive and pulling
together a collection of documents but
she also participated in writing history
the vernacular history making is the
concept that you know I pulled from it
was Joann
she said it's particular she making
there it is it's in the book but so she
published a piece most recently in
Louisville says but onset comes out of
the Esperanza Center in San Antonio
Texas and so she wrote a lyrical a Honda
to her cousin and his name is Ricardo
Martinez and he helped to restore the
homestead of Antonio Longoria in in
Antonia Longoria and so the the oral
histories that I thought that note about
Longoria living has helped to record of
the accounts of the children that were
in the house the day that these men came
to take horses
he's preserved for example like the same
window that they looked out of and
described in their oral histories is is
still in the home that he's preserved so
this is the kind of vernacular
history-making that I write about in the
book as being an important political an
important historical contribution but
also speaking back to the tradition that
celebrates the Texas Rangers or that
celebrates this period of racial
violence but that's a tall task because
you know we also remember that Walter
Prescott Webb wrote hit published his
first you know canonical account of the
Texas Rangers in 1935 when he described
indigenous people as savages and
Mexicans as
you know having dirty water for blood
and that became inscribed in in Texas
history and he because he helped to
build public history in Texas and so the
book coming out in 1935 was influential
in the celebrations of the Texas
centennial in Texas so Texans celebrate
Texas independence and so in 1936 he
helped to install over a thousand
monuments across the state of Texas and
to inspire exhibitions at the Texas
Centennial like the you know the Junior
Rangers with the pledge like a good
Ranger I'll be brave honest obedient and
always keep my eyes out for danger and
so this is actually a pledge that
students that young generations can
still take it's sponsored by the Texas
Ranger History Museum in Waco Texas but
of course you know generations have also
been brought up watching The Lone Ranger
and Walker Texas Ranger and so the work
of the the families and descendants have
had to take on and trying to commemorate
these histories of racial violence or
speaking back to myths that have been
ingrained in public understandings of
the past and so I a little bit lost for
time because I don't have a clock okay
so here we go so I'm gonna wrap up just
by showing okay so then there's also the
baseball Texas Rangers I don't know if
you mean Rangers fans I mean yeah so
there's there's that guy there's Bush
but then there's this I have another one
I wish that I had one with with his with
his mother with the former first lady
because it's really charming actually
she looks really cute in a baseball cap
but but this is also the Wayne go to
Waco Texas Ranger History Museum and I
write a review of the of the museum in
my book and I was saying earlier that I
thought you know after I was reading it
like wow that was really tough and then
I visited the museum again just a week
ago and I found even more that I could
have really amped it up actually I think
there's a lot of work that we have to do
in in having a truthful accounting of
the past encouraging cultural
institutions across the state to
participate in
with full accounting of the past and
there are some institutions you know not
just this but across the state that
actually have very that have racist
depictions of the past and I don't use
that word lightly but you know in
working with descendants of racial
violence and and this group that I
helped to start called refusing to
forget we started organizing in 2013 to
pull together public commemorations
because we recognize that despite the
dozens of books that documented this
period of racial violence it those
academic the the the the the progress
that we had made in professional
conversations and understandings of
history had not changed public
understandings of the past and so we
were thinking about having you know an
exhibit at ut-austin at the center you
know sponsored by the Center for
mexican-american studies and we were
thinking of raising funds for one
monument or marker some sort of statue
artist installation and when we talked
to people like node my long ago dia when
we had our first organizing meeting I
invited descendants like Noor Longoria
Rodriguez and the Alvarado's who are
descendants of the bought deed massacre
and they very adamantly said and what is
the state going to do so the peak of
violence occurred in 2015 we had been
planning for 2015 and they said and what
is the state going to do because we have
been memorializing these histories on
our own we have been documenting them on
our own we have our own events what is
it going to take for the state to
finally acknowledge its role in this
period of violence and so it shifted our
whole or all of our strategies and so we
utilize the under-told marker program in
Texas which is actually a phenomenal
program since 2006 they have unveiled
over a hundred markers across the state
that tell under-told histories of Texas
and so what it does is it creates an
opportunity for anybody in Texas and any
historian to submit
application for an under-told marker and
it does not require a county to nominate
to sponsor the application and so in
some of the cases of episodes of racial
violence that I have documented the
counties are opposed to having a marker
like this and so when you submit it
directly to the state the state can
approve or disapprove the application I
actually had to apply for this one three
times but we just unveiled it on
Saturday and so it was tremendous
we had 175 people attended the unveiling
ceremony we had descendants participated
we had a blessing and and it was
incredible but we had like a three-day
public history extravaganza and so we
had a conference that day and this is
here
Melba cootie and knowing I'll go to
Vegas and we've got them at Venus and
they spoke about their own work
preserving the history how they learned
the history and then what they did to
try to make it public and this is
Christine melis Melba Cody's daughter
who was really instrumental in getting
the photographs on display in the
Bullock and that's me and then we also
had a history harvest we collaborated
with utrgv Special Collections to give a
workshop to utrgv students on how to
digitize photographs documents and how
to conduct oral histories and so that
was my part and we also in terms of the
spirit of collaboration this is Valerie
da meatus and she's a member of the eval
County Historical Commission and so the
we had support from local universities
from the archivists from the students
but also from the local County
Historical Commission in this case the
County Historical Commission was really
supportive but they also are not always
tech savvy so figuring out how to fill
out the application in the PDF they also
had a president of the the Chairman who
wasn't hospitalized and so you know this
is all volunteer and so this was ended
up being a tremendous opportunity for
collaboration and so I'm hopeful about
the future and possibilities for making
public change
through engaged public history work but
I'm also painfully aware of the climate
of this work so most people know about
you they'll go County or places like
McAllen because of it was ground zero of
family separation in every County where
we are unveiling historical markers
there are multiple detention centers for
immigrants you know I wrote in the
epilogue of the book also makes direct
parallels between the families like
Miguel Garcia who were literally
searching the landscape for the remains
of his son and families today who were
doing that same work and so I'll just
speed through here but you know
golly buddy this is a center for human
rights and I am gripped by the roles of
families you know who are again
preserving the names of their loved ones
who disappeared when crossing into the
United States who are calling on the
state to remember the names and the
faces of their loved ones
and and you know the over 6,000 people
have died since 1994 and deterrence
policies funneled people seeking refuge
in the United States through the desert
in Arizona and through the treacherous
parts in Texas and so literally in some
the same counties in Texas where loved
ones were a hundred years ago looking
for the remains of their husbands and
children and and daughters families are
doing the same work of trying to
identify the remains of people who have
died and so so I'll stop there to answer
any questions that people have about the
public work the history itself the
recovery work and and and look forward
to to a good conversation
[Applause]
sure I can feel a question yeah mm-hmm
yes
oh there's a microphone yeah so you were
asking about vernacular history making
the politics memory
mm-hmm yeah well I think you know
unfortunately there are still a good
number of historians that are skeptical
of oral history so you know I
intentionally put that section in in the
book in the introduction about the
possibilities of oral history I mean you
know we have known the possibilities for
decades but I also thought that you know
people who maybe are not historians
might read this book and there's always
a sort of quick dismissal of oral
history as evidence and so I'm really
interested not only in studying memory
and in conflicting memories so the first
chapter looks at the the lynching of
Antonio Vegas and really there are no
family members in that town he's you
know he is burned alive at the stake
in November in 1910 and he is understood
to have just been passing through town
or have been a migrant laborer so he
didn't have roots there but that
lynching continued to shape the racial
politics and society in the town for
over a hundred years and so there are
these competing accounts you know was it
justice in action did he really
murder Effie Grier Henderson or was he
just a proxy and was it really somebody
else and was it actually a brutal brutal
immoral act of mob violence and so those
tensions coalesce in the town and they
don't fall along racial lines and so
that was something interesting that I
wanted to point out in the book that
there are competing memories and they do
different work and so the circulation of
an account of the lynching by civil
rights activists in the 60s and 70s for
example animated a particular kind of
organizing right that that young Chicano
and Chicana eyes were imagining
themselves as responding to long
histories of violence and discrimination
right and so sharing that story helped
to mobilize a certain kind of awakening
or consciousness and in another in
another context sharing that account
warned a Mexican chief here not to have
relations with white women right that
even proximity to white women is
dangerous and so I was interested in
what kind of like when did people decide
to share this story and what was the
lessons that were being conveyed but
also how is it that a hundred years
later people were still remembering this
event but then they also as a historian
you know for people who think that you
know memory is you know not serious work
interested in using oral histories for
what they expose in in archives and so
for the for the Bonita massacre for
example if I hadn't conducted the oral
history with the Alvarado's I would not
have found the court case that was filed
by the widows in 1926 and so 12
survivors of that massacre filed a claim
against the US government which led me
to other cases of Mexican nationals that
had filed cases against the US
government seeking indemnities and so it
led me to a legal archive that
historians hadn't found and so so part
of the work so there's the stud but the
study of memory itself and then there's
the use of oral histories that point you
to archives that haven't been analyzed
and and again thinking about the work of
normal embody other was vaguest to
prompt me to ask different questions and
so I think that the work and the
importance of oral history is multiple
and it just takes you know if you pull
together the right committee that
understand the politics of the questions
you know so I was taking classes with
Alicia
you know who was thinking about how is
it that people seek justice in the face
of negligence by the state right I was
thinking about less mother so it applies
either mile for example and that what is
the work that women were doing just
showing up publicly to mourn and so that
helps me ask new questions as well but
it also helps me engage you know just
questions of what does it mean to take
on the question of what is loss what
does it mean to analyze loss and so I
really was working with historians and
people in cultural studies and building
this interdisciplinary project but I had
a committee
that understand the politics of the work
and the urgency of the questions and so
I think part of it is finding the right
methods in articulating the methods that
help you answer the questions that feel
urgent to you
and sometimes it maybe just means
pulling together the right group of
people you know joined meyerwitz from
what I know unless she's you know had
this whole other life before wasn't
studying the borderlands but she could
understand having a feminist practice
for our doing archival work and so I
think it's I would I had this really
excellent synergy with my committee
mm-hmm but it's an important question
first of all Thank You professor
Martinez my name is David and I'm
actually from Brownsville so this is all
very relevant to my upbringing but I'm
I'm aware of how Brownsville and South
Texas are now as demographic wise but
what is Brownsville in South Texas look
like in 1910 to 1920 when the silence is
happening what's sort of the
distribution of the demographics is it
what are suppose what percentage of
Mexican immigrants are there living in
these areas oh the question of
percentage is I'll have to send you the
numbers of that because I don't have it
offhand but in terms of the the the
demographics are changing so you really
have by 1904 the railroad arrives in
Brownsville and it brings with it Anglo
migrants you know Anglos who are coming
from the south and who are coming from
the north who are bringing in new ideas
about race and racial hierarchies and so
there had been a longer effort to dis to
remove a Mexican land owning community
but also Mexican residents many who are
American citizens who were also engaged
in politics and in voting who were
engaged in educating their children and
so you have this what was introduced as
his Oren's called the Juan Crow bringing
Juan Crow laws of racial segregation to
South Texas and so that included
segregating children from schools
prohibiting interracial marriages
you know banning ethnic Mexicans from
participating in juries and also using
racial intimidation for
disenfranchisement also think passing
things like poll taxes and and so there
was this effort really to create this
new racial hierarchy and when laws and
implementing laws weren't as effective
especially in trying to displace
landowners then racial violence was used
and so you the the the common phrase in
this era was you don't buy from the
husband you buy from the widow right so
you murder the husband and then you
intimidate the widow and you then take
land that way but there's what's what's
happening in terms of the shifting
economy is that this this migration of
Anglos changes the way that land is used
and so Texas changes from a primarily
ranching economy in South Texas to a
farming economy so it's also been
described by the v20 hanno as the farm
colonization of the Southwest and so you
so you see that the change in the use of
land but also Mexicans move from being a
landed you know landed members of the
landed elite to primarily being wage
laborers and so it's a shifting of the
racial hierarchies now of course it's
important to remember that this is
they're layered histories of
colonization right so Antonio Longoria
for example has his land and couldn't be
traced back to a Spanish land grant
right so so there are histories of
colonization that and and the patterns
of policing that targeted different
racial and ethnic groups right you know
some of the Texas Rangers that are in
this Hall of Fame are celebrated for
participating in massacre and genocide
of indigenous people in Texas some of
them are also celebrated for being slave
catchers I mean I'm not exaggerating
they describe people as slave catchers
and promote that in their bios of some
of these Texas Rangers and so so it is a
it's a place where the history of of
genocide all colonization in the history
of slavery in the history of
u.s. Empire and nation building are all
colliding and in the early 20th century
you see these tensions being targeted at
I think Mexicans it's a complicated era
but if the numbers I'll have to send
them to you hello thank you so much my
name is Phil mundo I loved your book
could you please speak to the section on
Dairy Queen I just thought it was so
phenomenal how it's such a public space
and yet like the way that you unpacked
the history and how photographs there
have normalized violence just what that
experience was for you seeing that as
you were working through this project as
you were writing it as well and then
also a broader question just about
capitalism and how it influenced like is
this could it be conceptualized this
work as like a history of capitalism as
[Music]
postcards are printed with like people
like dying or dead on the postcards
how does violence become a form in which
capitalism grows or is perpetuated
mm-hmm okay those are great questions
well I mean to talk about the Dairy
Queen briefly you know it was an eerie
experience so I you know driving home to
see my family in eval D because I had
been doing archival work and then I
stopped in a Dairy Queen which is you
know on these road trips you need to go
to the bathroom you need some iced tea
and so ass Avenel is is not to you know
maybe 20 miles from where my parents
live in Nevada but they but anyhow so
there was a Texas Ranger a photographic
exhibit honoring the Texas Rangers and
so it included photographs of a lynching
and so it was this moment I had been
conducting his archival work on the
history of anti-mexican violence and
this was one of those other moments you
know talking to know about Al Gore's
Vegas and having pie with her was one of
these moments talking to the Alvarado
son ovale about the boy Anita massacre
and hearing about the conversations
where they had talked to the local
County about having historical marker
and been dismissed you know or travel
to archives and seeing you know
archivists pull documents out of the
folders that they requested you know
there were these other moments where I
thought that the need to study oral
history is also about studying the
politics of how history is produced and
what who it's serving and who was
committed to protecting a version of
history how is power memory and history
all coalescing so this exhibit this
Dairy Queen exhibit with this this
lynching these lynching photographs for
me is a really profound example of the
kind of racial intimidation that people
are exposed to right so for people who
identify with victims of racial violence
who say that might look like me or that
reminds me of somebody from my family
who was treated that way you know that
is the kind of image that reminds you of
what your place is right
there's is but they're similar it's not
you know a lynching photograph but also
you know the the wrought iron signs
across the state you know it's like
Texas you know kitsch you know we don't
call 9-1-1 and it's got you know the
Colt 44 revolver you know it's like
metalwork and people put them on their
homes and shops have you know posters
that say like we we don't call the
police we prosecute shoplifters and it's
got you know people on a scaffold before
being pained and so these kinds of
images I was really struck by not only
the way that it had been curated because
there were no captions you didn't get
the sense of you know this could have
been in Sabinal it could have been
anywhere we didn't know who the victims
were but the way the kind of work that
it was doing and talking to the women
that worked there saying things like I
don't like to take out the trash because
I don't want to look at those
photographs but also that the person who
curated the exhibit was so happy to talk
about the Texas Rangers right so he was
part of creating the reenactment groups
and celebrating this era of Texas
Rangers in particular from like the you
know the 1880s through the nineteen
teens and so it was also then an
experience to try to to to give space
for thinking through what is the
interest in somebody in these
reenactment groups in
creating these the celebration and being
a part of participating in vernacular
history making you know not to dismantle
these mainstream narratives but to
reinforce them and especially in rural
communities where people don't have
access to cultural institutions right
the Dairy Queen is what you do he knows
where old men drink coffee and so I was
really interested in how these politics
play out in ways I mean it's racism in
plain sight right so people think about
monuments Confederate monuments coming
down but this is another history that is
just celebrate without because people
because most people don't know this
history or they do and they really do
think that this is progress right they
really do think that Native Americans in
this era were savage and so for them
this is they're honoring Texans that
helped to build the state so that's
interesting you had a second question
though I think so I mean certainly if
you I mean if you're thinking about the
commodification of I mean the ways in
which racial violence was also used to
suppress union organizing labor
organizing and also to intimidate a
vulnerable labor force certainly I mean
there's a long history of Texas Rangers
and border patrol being used to suppress
you know efforts for labor rights or
also just to you know deport laborers
before payday so there's a there's the
inter the history of policing is deeply
interconnected with the exploitation of
Labor and the recruitment of vulnerable
labor and then the exploitation of that
labor but but in the terms of the
commodification of the postcards
certainly the it's a there's a history
you know the history of photography in
this era you know there's the the use of
Muscovy as the convergence of you know
wartime photography you know the
photographers that are taking
photographs of the Mexican Revolution
but also of the development of this you
know the the cell of these postcards as
souvenirs right
it's a way that you create not only a
market that celebrates this kind of
dehumanization and photography but you
also see the wider circulation of the
criminalization of Mexicans and so you
see the figure of the Mexican bandit
taking root in Texas but then also
change creating a national figure of the
menacing Mexican that we are still
living with today so this was not just
the postcards but also the political
cartoons and you know in another version
you know when I've given talks to bigger
public audiences you know I show some of
those political cartoons right it's this
it's this moment when you see the
crystallization of of Mexicans as bandit
as foreigner as threat being cemented oh
there's two so maybe you both ask and
then and then I'll combine them really
quickly
okay so my name is Larissa thank you for
your talk I mean I think this is really
important work but yes I guess my
question is like where do we go from
here like I think it's really
interesting that you chose Texas and
then they would like this I just think
it's sort of ironic considering like
Texas is also like the like produces
text books and and it's like a lot of
yeah it's like missing so much
information and so I guess I don't know
what what role do you think that books
like yours can play in like teaching
more of the community and like how do we
make those things also like accessible
because I know a lot of times like
academic papers are written for people
but in academia and sits
yeah like sometimes it's really hard to
then go back to like for example rural
communities and try to just be like no
actually with all that they thought you
was wrong so like how can you really
have engaging dialogue where like people
can start seeing yeah like seeing this
without also I mean the history is
really violent and I can yeah and also
you've been like how do you begin like
teaching children like at what like what
ages but I don't know yeah these are
really important questions and these are
some of the questions that I don't have
all the answers for but you know one of
the things for refusing to forget that I
started to do you know one of the things
was to build a yeah quickly ask your
question we'll talk at dinner yeah okay
we have time okay so really quickly
though but it was to write a part of the
public work for refusing to forget you
know as I brought students on at Brown a
group of graduate students and
undergraduate students and we wrote a
curriculum for de curriculum on Hovey
day that right so again how do you tell
this history this brutal history of
racial violence to children which is not
mice that's not my skill set but so we
developed this lesson planet it can be
modular so that you know teachers can
use different different parts of it but
it gives a history of this racial
violence a history of the Texas Rangers
and the brutality but it also gives the
history of homothug right who not only
was a journalist who literally stood in
front of the Texas Rangers to try to
keep them from burning down a printing
press they eventually burned it down
but before they do
you know she also wrote these newspaper
articles documenting the atrocities she
also organized for women's suffrage she
also organized for access to public
schools by these Mexican children and
she also helped build the first you know
cross-border civil rights conference so
it's pretty medical in good esselman he
konista and she had and she organized a
women's conference alongside it and so
it was this conference that invited
people from both sides of the border
right because in this era there was not
really a border people moved fluidly
back and forth and so she imagined civil
rights organizing in a fight for social
justice having to be a cross border
coalition and so bringing these sort of
radical calls for justice bringing a
figure like Kobe bata to a public
audience to an elementary-school
audience to me was a really captivating
opportunity and it's something you know
we matched it up so it fulfills the teks
you know knowing that every student in
Texas and public schools has to take
Texas history in K through 12 and if
they're a university student they have
to take it again that's a big group of
students so making it fulfill the
requirements that a teacher would need
to teach that in a Texas history class
now you know my parents walked out of
schools in 1970 to protest
discrimination and segregation in
schools and one of the things that they
demanded was mexican-american studies be
taught in public schools and finally in
2019 it's going to be offered by
teachers and school districts that
support it but students can get state
credit for taking mexican-american
studies and so I'm part of a group of
historians that are just hustling to try
to help develop curriculum and so the
Aibileen de valència who is a descendant
of the beloved Eve massacre has has
written some lesson plans about the
board meeting Massacre and so we are
working really actively to figure out
how you reach a younger audience I
paired up with Professor Chris God Mona
who just wrote a book called Elaine [ __ ]
so it's a it's a piece of fiction about
this era but it's for young adults right
so there are and and there's a there so
there's that is an active effort but I
think that
you know having the Historical Marker is
one thing having the book is one thing
but then how you actually activate the
history to shape and change public
understandings of the border and of
immigration you know my sister is an
artist and she says you know the border
people know the border as a place of
horror but it's a she knows it as a
place of hope so
we need to get back there thank you and
actually you answer the question I
wasn't asked about the Buffalo oral
history and that role that oral history
allows academics to not only produce
academic research but also leading to
public history right and how that takes
place but you use a serrated yeah I mean
I think part of it is that there's just
for me I think that as a historian or
people who study histories of racial
violence that once you have learned
these histories and once you are
starting to help document these
histories for public for publication for
academic work that we have a moral
obligation to make sure that it's
available to a wider public and so and I
also felt a moral obligation for these
families who had been working to try to
make these histories public for over 100
years to leverage my PhD to do some of
that work right so you know and we've
received a considerable an amount of
resistance most recently and I am still
concerned there's still a lot of good
work that public history can do and I'm
very hopeful but I also now see that
there is possibility for some of these
efforts to create harm and so for a
descendant of the boudin master to read
you know local members of a County
described their family members as
bandits and as rapists and to say you
know awful things in public
correspondence or to describe them as
you know militant Hispanics I you know
the the progress that we have made is
invaluable but again it's about
recognizing that the urgency for making
this history public is because we are
living in a violent context we are
living in another era where troops are
being sent to the border where
immigrants are being where people who
are seeking refuge asylum seekers are
being imprisoned and and where there is
a rise of white supremacy and racial
hate and so in in this era we have had
some very good luck finding partners and
allies in the state to help have a
truthful accounting to show real
leadership but I'm also seeing that now
as some of these events have become more
public and we've received more attention
that there is now actively an active
effort to stop the progress and so in
some cases it has exposed a a troubling
part of Texas so but I'm more determined
than ever so you know the book is out
there's nothing they can do about that
the marker is up but nothing they could
do about that
so you know determined to keep making
more progress
[Applause]
[Music]